hi I'm at Checkers and this is where the
presidents of Ukraine is coming fairly
soon we expect sometime this morning for
as you said substantive negotiations so
it seems slightly different in tone to
the last visit he um he uh came here he
made here where he gave that speech at
Westminster Hall and met with the Prime
Minister was made uh commitments in
terms of what kind of weapons can be
given and in terms of what Britain's
committed that has been followed through
on we've heard now that Storm Shadow
missiles have been given to the
ukrainians possibly already used K over
the weekend some speculation that they
were used to or at least one was used to
strike a Russian Target fairly deep
Behind Enemy Lines that not confirmed
yet though and this visit here's the UK
follows president salencia going to
Germany where he met the chancellor Olaf
Schultz and also to France where he went
Emmanuel macron the French President
also to the Vatican where he met the
pope now the message it seems the thrust
behind this visit seems to be his
impatience at the speed at which or the
slow speed at which Western weapons are
get getting through to Ukraine so
there's been a lot of commitments a lot
of promises made particularly over
weapons like modern battle tanks and I
think there's been an admittance on the
behalf of various Western countries that
particularly tanks aren't getting
through to the ukrainians quickly enough
those British challenge attacks have
reached there have already been already
being used in training at least but in
terms of other tanks leopard tanks in
particular Abraham's tanks from America
not enough getting through to Ukraine
the Abraham's tanks will take a lot
longer to to reach there so I think
there's an impatience on the behalf of
the ukrainians they're not seeing these
weapons get there quickly enough and I
think they're worried that their their
counter offenses they're
counter-offensive they're much vaunted
counter-offensive that they want to
launch against the Russians can't really
begin until they get all those weapons
so this is a Whistle Stop tour around
Western countries European countries
France Germany and now Britain to try
and increase the speed at which those
crucial weapon supplies get through to
the Ukraine so they can begin this
offensive